let's assume this is an awesome movie do
you think it's gonna get a sequel of
course it's gonna be like Lethal Weapon
yeah
then you lethal weapon I have an idea
for a Lethal Weapon 5 that I'm gonna
talk about soon no it's great itit's
it's seriously a good idea that we're
gonna happen yeah I know
but if they did it I would know how to
do okay okay cool it's really good right
tuck that in with your dream for a
four-way hi I'm filming I'm Greg hello I
am Jeff ich away yep javi
Kawai is here my brother from the same
mother with different last names
different last names our mother had
different lessons at different times in
her life yeah she was someone who got
men everywhere she went just she was a
very busy person she was a very busy
person handling several relationships at
once speaking of nice sons the nice guys
with Ryan Gosling and Russel Crowe I
want to see this movie already just
because I love Shane black and I love of
course Ryan Gosling and Russel Crowe who
is awesome too jor-el Man of Steel Body
of Lies but I love Body of Lies you I
love Body of Lies if you haven't seen
Body of Lies that's a great [ __ ]
movie I loved bought it was it's really
good you didn't see it I saw you didn't
like it
no oh I thought it was awesome hell yeah
March Jackie Lee don't get upset I'm not
either
urge you look away you know there's a
berry here right what do you want people
say you're pretty good detective it's
very moist
well look who decided to show up for
class
this is a high-profile case seeing this
girl one's a million-person for me we
can do this the easy way
now currently doing it the easy way
there's our course hearing stuffs we
don't know many times have I told you
don't say I'm stuff just say Dada there
are horse here even I think this is
gonna work better if you split up wow
this really insensitive
you're in the pool yeah why I had to
question the mermaids what were you
doing while I was working in this case
is down the mob is trying to spread its
operations so he's got this great
soundtrack
promise me you get them rose promise ah
March that was a deadline new photo
solving the crime of the century
let's deal with the rotting corpse Oh
weapon on the floor it's not you you're
not a murderer
it's just like you people Kiss Kiss Bang
Bang Oh
nice landing
he got invincible I think I can die but
me it's not the small idea the world's
worst attack those cool head don't major
hits Markus I know you're sensitive
about time how big is that's just like
kiss kiss been going he said he wanted
to make it you know like in a similar
vein to it some obvious ones that I've
said about past trailers
I love Russell Crowe already Ryan
Gosling I really like what he's doing
here because he's doing something
different especially going against the
current image that we have of him no
it's allowing him to do like a very much
more physical comedic role you know he
gets to showcase a new style of himself
and it's not like the hot leading kind
of cool guy you know I think it's bold
that he's finally doing something like
this is usually the romantic type lead
we're usually the cool guy like in your
favorite movie Drive what else is the
notebook really did drive he did you see
the place beyond the pines I did I love
that movie though he leaves again he was
amazing you know film but he was still
like the cool guy next I mean Ryan
Gosling is the definition a cool guy so
the fact that he's not the cool guy and
I like Russell Crowe kind of playing to
his new kind of image he is like a lot
more husky now he's gained a lot of
weight but he still looks like a tough
[ __ ] and I like seeing that like
you sided and I'm pretty sure he's a
tough [ __ ] I'm now he's always
yelling that way yeah but he's an Aussie
now he has like I'm like oh you know
physical presence though oh yeah he
looks like someone you don't want to
mess with how do you feel about the
stories so far it's very reminiscent of
Kiss Kiss Bang Bang like we said before
exciting like Russell Russell Crowe is
clearly like the Val Kilmer care if you
got cat hair in my face
he's like the Val Kilmer character
except he's straight I think Ryan
Gosling is clearly the Robert Downey jr.
character yeah
very goofy and kind of [ __ ] himself
up left and right the dynamics in that
sense are the same but I feel like the
characters are still different he
punched through the glass and he cut up
his hand Robert Downey jr. lost a finger
hand related issue he actually lost that
thumb a thumbs this will still hand
related issue you know really those guns
in both of them really white people to
white people in both
really and the only difference between
the two is this is set in the 70s and
Kiss Kiss Bang Bang is set in the 2000s
and that's why I'm looking forward to is
the fact that it's in the 70s you know I
want to see Shane black explore that
territory I feel like he's a much more
advanced director now especially coming
off of Iron Man 3 what else is he done
using he did Kiss Kiss Bang Bang he
wrote the first Lethal Weapon okay it
was really young when he wrote that
movie and you know he's doing the new
predator movie okay what is the actual
story of this though well I think he is
kind of a con artist
Ryan Gosling and Russell Crowe inm are
the unlikely duo because Russell Crowe's
got a mission and he needs Ryan
Gosling's help to finish that what is
the mission I don't remember I have no
idea I just remember the characters
being compelling to watch I don't like
sounding stupid on camera I told you
this a private eye investigates the
apparent suicide of a fading porn star
in 1970s LA and uncovers a conspiracy
okay you know it's kind of like a fun LA
Confidential and it's cool that Kim
Basinger isn't it to Basinger whatever
passenger that's one more Simpson would
say yeah it's cool that she's in it too
because you know like she was in LA
Confidential and now she's in this movie
it's sort of like the fun version of LA
Confidential that bathroom scene was
really funny it was very nice it felt
very natural and real that's what I
liked about it like him [ __ ] up felt
realistic you see that's what I'm
wondering because Shane Black is known
to write some pretty solid screenplays
but I feel like he actually allowed for
a lot of improv Navy you know days Ryan
Gosling the type to improvise totally
indicated by what movies Blue Valentine
al Qaeda in sequel Valentine oh my god
is she amazing and he improvised a lot
of Crazy Stupid Love I did see that you
do you're missing out I amazing
performances of Ryan Gosling
you know Remember the Titans I'm into
that wait was that with Denzel
Washington yes I saw that I don't
remember him being in that movie them
well he had a good five minutes okay you
know it's cool about this too is when I
first heard that Russell Crowe Ryan
Gosling we're doing a movie together in
the 70s like private eyes I was like
that's that's gonna be really cool
actually it's gonna be like an awesome
period piece drama and then I saw the
trailer the first one I was like oh it's
how do I expect it a shame like it's a
total comedy and it's cold up in her
first pair up is a comedy that still
allows for them to be characters instead
of just you know to cool celebrities
hanging out what I'm interested also in
seeing is Ryan Gosling's dynamics with
his kid that looks like it's gonna be a
fun aspect to the film has he had a kid
in any previous films Blue Valentine
oh and place beyond the pines he had a
kid but like there was no relationship
there so this is the first film where
that I'm aware of that I you get to see
him actually have a relationship with
this kid yeah yeah well it's cool to see
him have kids no I just as a character
he hasn't he has a child already and he
has a and his wife is currently pregnant
Ewa Mendez so it technically has
one-and-a-half kids yeah technically 1.5
children something like that still in
development soon to be two children
this looks good well guys this video is
done do we run out of things to say yes
if you're new to the channel subscribe
today
it'll be worth my time and maybe yours
Jabby Co a death house channel where he
tends a lot to the Indian fans I do for
Indian trailers so if you're one of them
Indian fans were you just like Bollywood
and all that stuff they're probably
already subscribe to my channel yeah
more than likely often in seon yeah I'm
pretty sure you can follow me on
Instagram Twitter what about you
Instagram Twitter and YouTube yeah
periscope and I want to say thank you to
all you subscribers for being so kind to
me these days I love you and you love me
too
and that love can never be broken
unless you want subscribe